ONE WATER'S ASSISTANCE BECAME M
PRIZE, THERE WAS TERROR IN HIS
EYES.
EARLIER THIS MONTH I CHRIST AND
ARCH SHOW CALLED WATTERS
PRIMETIME.
THAT BASED OFF IN A GAME AGAINS
SINK OR SWIM DAY NOT WON BUT SH
FAILED A DRUG TEST.
THE PRIZE IS I ONE JOHNNY FOR
THE DAY PIT I WAS HOPING FOR A
SET OF STATEMENTS BUT YOU TAKE
WHAT YOU CAN GET.
IT WAS AN INTENSE BATTLE BUT
LIKE ME AT HOTMAIL MODEL CAMP,
FINALLY DOMINATED.
WE ARE PRESENTING YOU JOHNNY FO
A DAY.
MY ASSISTANT WILL BE YOUR
ASSISTANT FOR A DAY.
I AM CASHING IN ON THIS AND THE
THINGS I'M GOING TO DO TO HIM.
IF HE EVEN RETURNS.
EXPECTS YOUR LIFE IS GOING TO B
AMAZING.
HE'S GOING TO BE MY LUNCH.
YOU ARE NOT GOING TO MAKE THEM
WORK.
THANKS FOR HAVING US.
I BET MANY PEOPLE DIDN'T THINK
THAT I WOULD CASH IN ON MY PRIZE
.
BUT I DID.
HERE IS HELPING FILE I'VE HAD
SEVERAL NEW YORK LABOR LAWS.
WHAT'S A FEW LOTS OF DECENCY.
HELLO, GREG.
LOOK WHO SHOWED UP.
YOU ARE EARLY.
SPECTER ACTUALLY LATE.
THIS IS WHAT YOU'RE GOING TO
WEAR.
I GOT A LOT OF WORK FOR YOU TO
DO.
ALL RIGHT.
DON'T WORRY ABOUT THAT.
DON'T WORRY ABOUT IT.
YOU ARE HERE TO WORK.
COME ON IAN YOU LITTLE FREAK.
LIFE IS OVER.
THIS IS ANOTHER NORMAL DAY AT M
HOUSE I'M GOING TO HAVE TO DO
SOME LIGHT HOUSEWORK COME UP
PERHAPS ANY KIND OF NEEDS THAT
MY GUESTS HAVE.
HE DOESN'T SPEAK.
AND YOU HAVE A SEAT RIGHT THERE
PLEASE.
MY HELMET IS THERE.
YOU ARE NOT EATING ON THE JOB.
DO YOU KNOW WHAT'S IN YOUR FILE.
I WON YOU FOR THE DAY.
ON JESSE WATTERS SHOT AFTER
BEATING DANA PERINO PIERCE YOU
KNOW WHAT ELSE?
NOTHING.
THERE ARE NO RESTRICTIONS TO BU
CAN HAVE.
EXPECTS MAYBE WE SHOULD CALL
JESSE AND SEE IF THERE IS
ANYTHING.
>> IT IS JUST YOU AND ME AND MY
DESIRES.
I THINK MY KAYAK NEEDS CLEANING.
THAT'S NOT A EUPHEMISM.
JOHNNY, YOU'VE BEEN SITTING HER
FOR A COUPLE MONTHS NOW THAT
BEETS AND CLEANING UNFORTUNATEL
ALL I COULD FIND WAS THIS
TOOTHBRUSH.
THERE YOU GO PICK UP LOOKS LIKE
IT'S GOING TO GET DARK SOON.
SO I SHOULD PROBABLY GET STARTED
.
GOOD LUCK WITH THAT.
I WILL BE UPSTAIRS.
DON'T DISTURB ME IF IT LOOKS
LIKE I'M BEING DISTURBED.
TEAM LIKE YOU'D LIKE IT.
>> I WAS THINKING THAT IT WAS
REALLY HARD BECAUSE I AM SO
SMART BUT I'M ALSO SO PRETTY.
SINCE I'M SO SMART, PEOPLE DON'
REALIZE HOW PRETTY I AM.
>> FINAL YOU'RE DOING SOME REAL
WORK.
WHILE YOU'RE DOWN THERE, CAN AS
YOU TO DO SOMETHING FOR ME?
♪♪
OH, YES, BABY.
WHAT ARE YOU DOING DOWN THERE?
>> BACK IN A SECOND, GUYS.
I'VE GOT TO HIT THE JOHN.
THAT IS A LOT OF HOSTAGE.
>> JESSE, WE ARE GOING TO HAVE
TO CHANGE THIS GAME SHOW PRIZE.
THIS HAS BEEN REALLY CRAZY.
I DON'T KNOW WHAT ELSE YOU ARE
GOING TO MAKE ME DO.
I SHOULD ASK YOU, TYRUS.
>> DON'T TALK TO ME.
I'VE GOT NOTHING TO SAY.
NOTHING TO SAY.
WOW, MAN.
WOW.
I DID FULFILL THE OBLIGATION.
YOU DID.
WHERE IS HE.
IS HE OKAY.
>> HE NEVER CAME BACK.
DO YOU THINK YOU DID A FULL DAY
'S WORK?
>> I THOUGHT HE DID A GREAT JOB.
THAT THEY GOT WEIRDER.
>> THAT GOT VERY WEIRD.
>> THE CATTLE ABOUT WEIRDER.
>> NONE OF THAT UP THE CAMERAS
LEFT.
WE HAD SOME GREAT KAMI --
CAMEO SELF WALTER KERN AND KEITH
.
KEITH WAS THERE HE WAS EATING A
LOT OF HOT DOGS.
>> SURE APPEARS.
>> WHILE.
>> THINK WE ARE TREATED THE
FLICK FICA SKETCH ENOUGH ACTUAL
DOCUMENTARY.
THAT WAS A SKETCH.
THAT HAS GOT BILLED.
SPECTER WE HAVE AN EXTRA HELMET
LIKE THAT.
YOU KNOW THE FEEDING BOOGIE
NIGHTS, THAT HAS GOT FILLED.
THAT WAS THE SCRIMMAGE.
>> IT REALLY WAS.
>> YOUR HONOR, I WAS IN THE
SHORTY ROLL BUT I COULDN'T FIND
A YOUNG MAN TO THROW
FIRECRACKERS AROUND ME.
THAT IS PALATINE PICU DON'T
THINK THAT THEY ARE NICE CAPS?
YOU CAN'T SAY THAT STUFF
ABOUT HIS CALVES.
>> TOO LATE, KINKY LAD